[Musique]
françois poulet mathis bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france alors les députés
européens se prononce donc aujourd'hui
sur l'accord commercial post break site
conclu entre le 1 et le royaume uni
alors est ce que ça pourrait capoter
finalement aujourd'hui
non je ne crois pas parce que les
différentes commissions du parlement
européen ont déjà donné leur accord et
puis on imagine le parlement européen
finalement contredire cet accord et
surtout remettre un peu de désordre et
même beaucoup de désordre dans la mise
en place des relations commerciales
entre l'union européenne et le royaume
uni non je pense que là il n'y a pas de
grandes surprises attendent cet accord
va être approuvé par le parlement
européen
ce qui va permettre effectivement que
son application qui doit l'instant au
temporaire jusqu'au 30 de ce mois va
devenir définitive et donc là je pense
qu'effectivement on devrait y arriver
mais ça n'offre pas les problèmes qui
cet accord suscite et notamment celui
que vous venez d'évoquer celui du
protocole avec l'irlande du nord qui
reste toujours intacte on n'a toujours
pas réglé ce problème et je crains
beaucoup qu'on ne le règle pas de sitôt
et pourquoi l'institut les raisons pour
lesquelles effectivement c'est ce qui
bloque c'est tout simplement que
l'accord prévoie pour éviter le retour
d'une frontière terrestre entre
l'irlande du nord et la république
d'irlande en accord avec les accords du
vendredi saint pour éviter un retour de
la guerre civile et bien fini elle
manque que cette absence de frontières
nécessité tout bonnement à le
rétablissement d'une frontière non pas
entre les deux irlande mais en irlande
entre l'angleterre et l'île irlandaise
et voilà le problème parce qu on demande
simplement britannique finalement de
fixer une frontière à l'intérieur même
de leur territoire c'est ça qui est un
peu paradoxal et qui rend l'application
c'est un accord difficile et c'est bien
ce qui a provoqué d'ailleurs de la part
notamment des unionistes ceux qui sont
très favorables à minc
mu syndicaux et finalement de réagir
très violemment contre le rétablissement
d'une frontière en mer d'irlande
ça c'est le principal problème psa n'est
pas le seul il ya la paix s'il ya un
autre problème
voilà et la pêche également il faut
savoir qu'actuellement il ya à peu près
un cinquième seulement des licences qui
ont été et promise totalement pêcheurs
français aux pêcheurs du continent nos
savants qui ont été accordés si bien
qu'actuellement les pêcheurs de boulogne
et d'autres ports français par exemple
ne peuvent pas véritablement pêcher des
ressources halieutiques qui représente
quand même jusqu'à 70% de leurs de leurs
ressources
donc il ya un manque à gagner raison
pour laquelle le gouvernement français
vienne leur accorder une des subventions
importantes mais si cela devait se
prolonger la housse si on arrive devant
une région possible de tension fin
portes dans la manche entre les pêcheurs
britanniques et les pêcheurs français
voit deux raisons qui montre que cet
accord ne règle n'a pas réglé encore
tous les problèmes aient eu la question
lieu la crise sanitaire également et la
question de la vaccination avec les
britanniques qui eux on vacciner
massivement ce qui n'a pas été le cas de
l'union européenne qui portent plainte
d'ailleurs contre le laboratoire
astrazeneca est ce que ça peut avoir
d'autres conséquences sur cet accord
commercial
non je ne crois pas parce qu'il faut pas
faire de liaison entre las temps d'aimer
qui n est une crise très spécifiques et
d'ailleurs je pense que s'il n'y avait
pas eu breake site ça n'aurait pas
changé fondamentalement les choses
les anglais auraient pu de la même
manière adopté la politique sanitaire
qu'ils ont adoptées notamment avec
astrazeneca
ça n'aurait pas changé la seule chose
qui a pu changer c'est qu'effectivement
étant libérée d'un contraintes
européennes
ils ont négocié beaucoup plus tôt
finalement leur vaccin et alors que
l'union européenne peuvent vous le savez
a préféré à tous et un accord collectif
pour avoir une négociation d'ensemble
pour permettre à l'ensemble des 27 pays
de l'union de disposer à égalité
proportionnellement à leur population
les vaccins correspondants dont je pense
pas qu'il disons que ça complique un peu
les choses parce que
effectivement ça retarde d'autant la
mise à nu des véritables problèmes liés
par le mexique mais je pense que on va
s'apercevoir s'est rapidement une fois
que les choses vont se créer que la
pandémie va finir que finalement le
break si tous les problèmes liés aux
briques sites vont resurgir alors
l'accord commercial et les appliquer de
manière provisoire depuis le 1er janvier
boris johnson alors il ne l'a pas
vraiment respectée on l'évoquait après
avoir ratifié l'accord est ce que
l'europe elle a des moyens de pression
pour que le royaume uni respecte ses
engagements a bien c'est prévu dans
l'accord de commerce et de coopération
il est prévu en cas de non respect c'est
de cet accord des mesures éventuellement
de rétention qui pourrait par exemple
consister à remettre des taxes dire
entre l'union européenne et le royaume
uni c'est une des possibilités c'est en
toutes lettres dans l'accord et donc les
anglais seraient susceptibles d'être
sujet à des sanctions si effectivement
bon set
cette dérogation qu'il réclame notamment
sur le problème de l'irlande du nord
n'étaient pas respectés se poursuivait
ça pourrait effectivement poser un
véritable problème et donc des deux
côtés d'ailleurs des deux côtés l'accord
prévoit des mesures de rétorsion si l'un
ou l'autre ne respecte pas finalement la
parole donnée et après ces quelques mois
finalement qui du royaume uni où l'union
européenne et bien semble avantager par
par cet accord post break site
disons que clairement l'union européenne
va souffrir
effectivement deux s'accordent sur le
braille site je pense néanmoins que
l'économie britannique
ça a déjà commencé va véritablement
sentir les effets des conséquences de
l'accord si je compare tous les éléments
qui fait que le l'angleterre n'aura plus
accès à beaucoup davantage qu elle pour
laquelle elle avait des accès avec le
marché unique
elle va perdre beaucoup davantage que ce
soit sur les marchés financiers que ce
soit sur la facilité la liberté de
circulation des produits
il y aura beaucoup davantage qu'ils vont
poser un véritable problème on l'a déjà
vu un certain nombre d'entreprises
britanniques qui se posent des questions
ou quant au maintien des filiales
européennes sur le sol britannique
il va y avoir actuellement on les voit
pas parce que la pandémie cache un peu
lâche un peu la réalité de la crise
commerciale double les britanniques vont
connaître
d'une part à cause de la pandémie bien
sûr qu'ils aient qui affectent
l'économie britannique comme elle
affecte les économique de l'ensemble
bien de cette payement mais également
avec les conséquences du bric sea dont
on mesurera les effets une fois la
pandémie terminé merci beaucoup
françois paul et matisse pour votre
éclairage ce matin dans la matinale de
rtl france je le rappelle vous êtes
journaliste spécialiste des institutions
européennes